Pete Dave congratulations you made it
through to the final round
to be crowned the forged and fire
Champion you must Forge an iconic blade
from history
it's time to reveal what that weapon
will be
holy crap
the Crusader sword
dating back to the Middle Ages the
Crusader sword was the European Knight's
weapon of choice as they conquered the
Holy Land This single-handed
medium-length long sword also contained
a double edge that tapered at the end
making it the ideal weapon for piercing
the emerging plate armor that was found
on most battlefields the most famous
Crusader sword was the legendary
Excalibur wielded by King Arthur
Crusader sword was also carried by the
Knights Templar who were highlighted in
films like kingdom of heaven and Indiana
Jones in the Last Crusade
good luck we will see you in five days
my name is Peter Burt the first sword
that I made I gave to my high school
girlfriend she was not very excited
about it my strategy here is to make a
Damascus Billet which is a laminated bar
made up of multiple layers of Steel and
a jelly roll is a specific pattern in
Damascus where you actually roll the
steel up on itself kind of like a
cinnamon bun
pretty tight
the jelly roll has reached the point
that I need to get it into the hammer to
squeeze it down on itself
to forging this out
I got plenty of wet that's nice and toy
I feel great about what I've made and if
Dave beats it that means he's brought
something incredible
I'm Dave Roeder when I was 16. I
followed the sound of an anvil and I met
a man that was forging a knife got to
watch it being done and I've been making
knives ever since
I want to make sure that this is going
to perform without fail
everything's good there so I'm going to
put the blade in oh well I'm going to
pull it out just enough for it to flash
anytime that thing got hot in the Forge
it would work I could literally watch it
then
this is called a three pin
straightening method I'm gonna either
straighten this blade or I'm going to
snap it
I really don't like doing this
so luckily the blade didn't break in the
Vise I was able to fix the warp now I
gotta get this sword finished the handle
is Walnut and my overlay is a leather
band
I decided to put inside the handle a
riser underneath the leather it's
pleasing to the eye and it helps with
the grip
confidence level is pretty high I'm
really pleased with the outcome of this
I've got a great chance at this in the
end with the judges
foreign
while the Crusader sword was quite
powerful and effective on foot and sword
sword combat there is a method of
delivery that made it even more
destructive
from horseback
that Rider is going to use your weapons
to attack that ballistics gel torso
that's wearing a great Helm gorget and
tunic
okay I suggest we get out of the way I'm
very nervous full Gallop on Horseback
that's a lot of power to put into a
sword Dave you're up first are you ready
I ain't gonna get any right here three
two one engage
[Music]
nice hit that is absolutely awesome Pete
your sword's up next let's see some
blood
I feel great that my sword held up well
but it didn't cut through the cloth
armor to assess the damage and perform
the kill test I'm gonna hand you over to
Doug
okay Dave
it's got some weight to it
so you have your sword should feel a bit
heavy in the hand
slashing feels good
let's see if it'll cut
okay
foreign
you can see it points like a spear
beautiful thrusting capability
the Killer Pete
so I'm now testing for the flossing with
length
it's got a lot of weight to it
let's see what's going to do on a kill
test let's see
foreign
it will kill
all right gentlemen that concludes the
kill test now we're going to head back
to the forge where we are going to
perform the strength test
gentlemen a sword in combat went through
extreme stresses so to test this I'm
going to take five blows against these
femurs see how far through we can get
with each of your weapons
okay
Pete you ready I'm ready all right
and while I was chopping this this ring
up here pretty rough on the hand okay
happy that my sword is still in one
piece at the end of this
got about halfway through that bone
blowing pieces off of it
and still has an edge okay
nice job thank you
Dave you're up next you ready
sure
a lot of stress in that blade
I'm kidding you can see the edge folded
over yeah
sort of bent right around that point of
impact right there
you can see we chopped right through
this bone about three blows to crack
that open
well done
you've both been outstanding competitors
through three rounds of competition
but
there can only be one forged and fire
champion
Jay oh Pete that Damascus blade was
beautiful I mean getting all those welds
folded together grinding that all evenly
heat treating it the way you did it
stood up to all the tests you did a
wonderful job on that piece of Steel
I had a couple of issues with the way
your handle was put together with that
spacer the spacer really started chewing
into my hand
I just couldn't get a good grip up
around the top of this sword that's an
issue comments for Dave well Dave even
though their overall look of your sword
and the design of your handle was very
appealing obviously it was a heat
treatment issue during the tests your
blade folded over and that really bit
you in the testing Dave I love the
design of your blade very clean lines
your handle felt very good in the handle
it's sharp it thrust well but in the end
it failed when we started slicing the
bones Pete
you are the forged Empire Champion
congratulations
Dave your sword felt great in the hand
but when I used it on those bones boy it
just bent right over the top and a heat
treat issue like that we just can't let
that through
Dave did an outstanding job
please surrender your weapon
the judge's decision was what it was and
if I can't change it then why worry
about it Pete congratulations you're
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars that's pretty nice how do you
feel I feel great I feel really good I
think my wife we get to Hawaii we're
gonna lie back and relax she's had to
put up with me being gone for this
she deserves it
[Music]